we're now only around one week away from
apple's wwdc event where everyone is
expecting apple to reveal their brand
new m2 chip alongside some new
redesigned m2 max and let me tell you we
are very excited for these new macs
however we just got a crazy bombshell
leak from a reliable source that
confirms our worst suspicions about the
performance of the m2 chip so let's jump
right in now this league comes from
shrimp apple pro who's actually the
leaker who revealed the new dual hole
punch camera cutout design for the
iphone 14 pro that everybody agrees on
now so he's very reliable and getting
into the actual leak about the max it
first starts out with the leaks for the
a16 bionic chip now according to his
sources he is saying that the a16 bionic
will continue to use 5 nanometer from
tsmc and 5p now if you don't know what
that means the current a15 chip is
actually based on the exact same n5p
process which is the second generation
five nanometer node from tsmc so that
means there's literally gonna be no
difference because a lot of us were
expecting apple to go for the third
generation which a lot of people are
calling four nanometer which is actually
the third generation five nanometer but
this is even worse they're saying that
it's going to use the exact same process
as a 15 and he confirmed it with a
source from a list that says tsmc
ff5 which basically means it's still
five nanometer now the actual upgrades
that we should expect for the a16 are
slightly better clock speeds for the cpu
slightly faster ram lpddr5 ram and a
better gpu and right here once again he
confirms there is not going to be 4
nanometer for the a16 bionic chip
because samsung's in tsmc's 4 nanometer
is really just refined 5 nanometer which
is third gen but no we're not even
getting that we're apparently getting
the second gen n5p which we already have
but now let's get into the big deal he
talks about the next m series chip which
he says is the m2 which he all expected
however he says that the m2 is actually
gonna be based on the three nanometer
process and from the list it says tsmc
ff3 and it's actually going to be the
first custom arm v9 processor from apple
however he says that we are actually
getting one more chip that's going to be
coming out this year it's going to be
apparently
another one that's kind of based on the
m1 which he thinks it could be something
with the m1x or some kind of other name
and apparently it's coming with the same
updated avalanche and blizzard cores
that we already have on the a15 which is
very disappointing now the crazy thing
about this leak from trim apple pro is
that this actually matches up to
something that ming chico talked about
because ming said that this year for the
iphones only the pro models are getting
the a16 while the regular 14 and 14 max
are getting the a15 both with six gigs
of ram however the difference is the new
a16 will have lp ddr5 memory which is
exactly what shrimp apple pro said and
if you think about it if they're both
based on the n5p process it kind of
makes sense why apple would have both of
these chips a15 and a16 available across
the entire iphone 14 lineup because in
reality they're not that different and
this actually leads me to an even more
important point because a couple of
months ago minchiko actually mentioned
that the macbook air could get a
modified version of the m1 chip and that
the m2 chip would be delayed which is
literally exactly what shrimp apple pro
just confirmed he said we should be
getting another kind of m1 based chip
this year with the real true m2 being
delayed until next year which is crazy
because i didn't believe ming chi kuo
when he made this leak a couple months
ago march 8th saying that it's gonna
have an m1 chip processor no mini led
display a new redesign and more color
options i couldn't believe it but now it
kind of actually makes sense if this new
chip is actually based on n5p but going
even deeper chance miller who is the
editor-in-chief at 95 mac said that quo
told him that it could be a modified
version of the existing m1 and that the
actual m2 could be pushed to 2023 which
perfectly matches up to what shrimp
apple pro is saying but here is the main
detail he says really it just comes down
to marketing names and we all know
apple's history there because apple
could call it whatever they want to
because if you remember the 2020 ipad
pro they said it comes with the a12 z
chip well in reality it was literally
the exact same a12x chip from the 2018
ipad pro except with one extra gpu core
enabled and that allowed them to call it
the a12z which is just pure marketing so
here's my crazy little theory about
shrimp apple pro's new leak what if this
final soc of the m1 family of chips is
actually going to be modified and called
the m2 because apple could call it
whatever they want and they could just
delay the real m2 and then call that the
m3 and ik dave made a very good point he
said apple could easily just call a chip
with avalanche and blizzard cores the m2
and then the three nanometer one the m3
and same thing with serenby saying to be
honest apple could easily just brand
this as the m2 chip even if the upgrades
are minor and then here was my take on
that no matter what it actually becomes
it must be named the m2 because apple
did say that the m1 ultra was the last
chip in the m1 family they said that at
their last march 8th event so whatever
they do with the ship no matter how
minor it is no matter if it's mainly
based on the same n5p process this new
chip needs a new name and guess what
shrimp apple pro just added to his leak
this morning he says now my source
agreed that this new m1x chip the
modified version could be the m2 instead
yes officially in terms of marketing it
could just be modified and they could
call it the m2 with four avalanche four
blizzard and then 10 agx which is apple
gpus and in his opinion he thinks it's
going to be a huge upgrade from the m1
and now we have to answer a very
important question
why in the world would apple make the
a16 and that new m2 chip be based on the
same exact five nanometer and 5p process
that the 815 is already based on well in
my opinion i think it all comes down to
the lockdowns and supply issues because
we have been hearing that at least one
iphone 14 model is three weeks behind
schedule and there's a chance it could
be delayed so there are a lot of issues
going on in china right now that could
potentially lead to more and more supply
chain issues so maybe apple just said
hey screw it let's just stick to the
same n5p we're already using to take the
safest route possible and take as little
risks as we can maybe to maximize
profits because of the squeezed margins
so here's what i think apple is going to
do i think they're going to take this
modified chip and call it the new m2
chip because mark german already
reported that within the software there
were leaks where apple is testing at
least nine new m2 based macs with a few
of those actually being the m2 chip for
the macbook air the mac mini and an
entry-level macbook pro so what if apple
already decided to call this new
modified chip the m2 and went with it
and the reason i think it makes sense is
because mark german has already seen
evidence of the next generation m3 chip
going into an imac later on probably
next year so what if apple had the m2
they decided to delay it and call it the
m3 and then put in a modified version of
the m1 this year as the m2 and this of
course lines up to exactly what chance
miller was saying and quo and shrimp
apple pro but now i want to get into why
this is so disappointing because if the
a16 bionic will truly be based on the
same exact second gen five nanometer
tsmc and 5p process this means bad news
for the m2 chip and it basically
confirms the worst case scenario that i
had for the m2 which is basically that
is based on the a15 instead of a newer
generation third nanometer and this is
exactly what nine to five mac
leaked with an exclusive leak saying
that the m2 chip is known as statin and
it's based on the current a15 which i
really hoped wouldn't happen because i
was hoping it would be based on a future
a 16 instead so before i get into the
actual performance numbers and charts
that we should expect for the m2 chip i
want to explain why i think apple
decided to stick to n5p
for the m2 chip well first of all
samsung's four nanometer which is
basically the third gen five nanometer
has horrible yields for qualcomm
snapdragon 8 gen 1 ship apparently they
were so bad they were only 35
in terms of yield which means that if
they made 100 chips they would only keep
35 and they would throw away the rest of
them which is absolutely horrible and
apparently tsmc actually had better
results where they would get a yield
rate of over 70 percent and that's why
they're going to be used for the
snapdragon 8 gen 1 plus but even then if
you make 100 chips you still have to
throw away around 30 of them which could
be why apple decided not to go for third
gen 5 nanometer because they might be
trying to save as much money as possible
because the yields for five nanometer or
the first and second gen are amazing way
back in 2019 they reported yields of
over 80
which was already very impressive and
then a year after that in august of 2020
they said that their yields got even
better with yields of around 90
and now two years later i'm sure they're
probably sitting at around 94 95 based
on their own estimates so maybe that's
why apple chose to stick around to n5p
once again and this finally brings us to
the performance this is actually a video
right here that i made around five
months ago with two different scenarios
one scenario is that the m2 chip would
be based on the a15 which i really
didn't want to happen and the other one
is it would be based on the a16 and now
it looks like it is gonna be based on
the worst case scenario a 15 so let me
show you guys the performance that we
should expect first of all in terms of
single core cpu performance instead of
around 17 14 points for the m1 the
second gen m2 chip should be around 1876
which honestly isn't that big of a
difference because with the scenario two
it would be over 2 000 which would be
awesome but unfortunately it looks like
that is not gonna happen and then moving
on to multi-core this is actually a
little bit of a better improvement
because instead of around 7400 the m2
chip based on the a15 should be around
8700 which is a little bit better but
the biggest difference we should expect
is actually in terms of the gpu as you
can see instead of getting around 21 000
points with the m1 the m2 chip should
get around 28 800 even though it's based
on the a15 and that's because we are
expecting two more gpu cores yes up to a
10 core gpu with the m2 so that's going
to be a big improvement right there so
with all that said it looks like the m2
chip is not going to be as good as we
thought it would be but it's still going
to be a decent improvement so hopefully
apple gives us some extra features and
changes with the actual mac itself to
make it more enticing maybe with like
wi-fi 6e bluetooth 5.2 in other new
features because it looks like the
performance difference is not going to
be that huge so if you disagree with my
thoughts on this video then comment them
down below but if you enjoyed it click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one definitely check
out one of those two right there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]